(Rick?:)Geez.(Jerry:) you speak the true-true. I'm in Cloud Atlas. What's Cloud Atlas?
How is this possible?
Infinite Timelines, infinite possibilities
including a timeline where Jerry's a movie star look you guys are getting excited about the wrong aspect of this device
Jus- what? Look at this!
*intro music*
Hello internet! Welcome to Film Theory, the Cromulon certified Schwiftiest show on the web.
Oh Yeah!
You gotta get Schwifty!
but you know what's decidedly not Schwifty?
That we still have MONTHS to wait before we can feast our eyes on season three of one of the best shows on TV
right now,
Rick and Morty.
Man! If only I could get my hands on Rick's portal gun and travel to an alternate dimension where the episodes are already out
Actually come to think of it
If I had a portal gun, I'd probably use it for other things.. There are a lot of attractive women there Morty!
They all wanted time with me. One of the reasons
I love this show so much and how it's always dropping really smart nerdy jokes about reality, science and philosophy
But it isn't above some good old-fashioned toilet humor. What Rick?! No, you can't! Too late Morty the hole's opening. No, no! Rick you don't understan- [fart]
There's just a lot more where that came from too! Ah the classic fart joke
But it's the characters in Rick and morty that are the best elements of the show. Jerry's soul-crushing
mediocrity. Morty's endless sexual frustration. Summer's endless quest to be popular and Beth's domestic
alchoholism. Actually that last one probably shouldn't be funny. But it is! Then of course there's Rick the enigmatic
Interdimensional genius. The end of season 2 leaves us with a cliffhanger that promises some kind of revelation about Rick's past
And that is what we're theorizing about today. Without getting too specific,
I'm gonna go ahead and warn you all now: Do not watch any further, if you haven't seen up through season two of Rick and
Morty. Check obligatory spoiler alert off the to-do list and~
Let's go. The fan community for the show has been losing their minds about rick getting jailed at the end of season Two's finale
How's he gonna get out is season 3 gonna start with an epic prison break a la
"Prison Break" style
But the biggest question of all is what did Rick even do to get locked up in the first place? Not much is known about
The circumstances surrounding his imprisonment. I mean, in the past
He's made some passing statements about having a lot of enemies
As you know Morty I've got a lot of enemies in the universe to consider my genius a threat
galactic terrorists, a few sub-galactic dictators, most of the entire intergalactic government
wherever you find people with heads up their asses. And at bird person's wedding he graces Beth with some casual wedding chatter. The road your
Father and I walked together is soaked deeply with the blood of both friends and enemies
Must be nice.
Then right before the vows are given it turns out Summer's friend Tammy is an undercover Narc for the galactic federation
And her wooing of bird person was all just an elaborate ruse to trap Rick and throw him into the big house
And that's it. That's all we know. we don't really know the specifics of why Rick is labelled as a terrorist.
It's widely accepted that the show's creators are withholding the answers to these questions,
waiting until the new episodes come out to reveal the specifics about Rick's mysterious past, but screw that why wait for them?
What if the answer to Rick's misdeeds are right in front of us already?
Hang on to your head hats because I'm about to show you what I got cuz honestly I think I got it all figured out
First here's a clip from the season 2 finale. And what are you in for? Everything.
I don't think Rick is being dismissive here. Rick is in prison because he hasn't just broken laws,
He's broken entire systems of laws and the realities that harvard them. Rick is
labeled a terrorist and thrown into prison because he is literally a serial destroyer of worlds
That's my theory anyway. Does it sound like a stretch?
It's not. For a prime example of Rick's
nonchalant world destroying antics, we only need to look at the end of the infamous episode: Rick potion #9.
It goes like this Morty realizes
It's gonna take a lot more than an evening of Netflix and chill to get Jessica to be his girlfriend.
So he asks Rick to brew him a love potion. When the potion's effects accidentally spread to the entire town, Rick's attempt at a cure
Doesn't quite go as planned.
The entire town gets transformed into classic 80s horror movie nightmares, and after another failed attempt at a cure the whole world
becomes infected, so what do Rick and Morty do? he finds a dimension that is
exactly like his current dimension, save for two things: One, the attempt to cure the world of the virus is
successful, and two, the Rick and Morty of that respective universe are seconds away from death. That way rick and morty from the infected
reality can simply bury the bodies of the deceased Rick and Morty take their place, and go on with their lives.
Now, you might be thinking that this is a really contrived solution to the show's problem.
It's awfully convenient that a reality exists in which everything is the same, except for those two variables
I mean
What are the chances that such a reality would even exist? Well,
according to the canon of the show, the odds are practically a hundred percent.
"There's an infinite number of realities Morty." Let me explain. The series Rick and Morty appears to adhere to what's known as Everett's
interpretation of quantum mechanics. Better known as the many-worlds interpretation
Before many-worlds, reality was always viewed as a single
unfolding history. A timeline where one event leads to another, leads to the next. Everett's
Interpretation however, proposed that reality is much less like a lime and more like a tree, with branches at [Keith's] point for other possible
outcomes are realized. To put it simply, everything that could possibly have happened in our past,
but didn't, has occurred in the past of some other universe. For instance the other week
I was in the theater and presented with a dilemma. A bag of perfectly good
popcorn on the ground. my moral quandary: do I eat that seemingly perfectly good bag of floor corn,
Or do I leave the floor corn where it belongs. On the floor. I even posted the debate on Twitter in the comments
raged Despite my better judgment and the popular vote
I decided to give the floor corn a pass, but by the many-worlds interpretation
There's a universe where I ate that floor corn and suffer the consequences of that decision whether it was reveling an artificial buttery goodness
Or getting the herb well floor corn aside. The same is true for Rick and morty in the show
There's a universe where rick decides to make the love potion for morty turning the world into Chaos and one where he doesn't and life
Goes on as normal. So if virtually every reality
Exists then Rick can dimension hop as much as he wants. Leaving behind destroyed old
realities and inhabiting new ones that conform to whatever condition he desires. And as you can imagine,
Rick jumping from One Universe Branch to another
Whenever it suits him is messing with the order of those other worlds. For instance if Rick and morty are supposed to be dead in
this new dimension they hopped to in Rick potion #9, their arrival from the
Cronenberg universe is throwing a whole new set of variables into an otherwise closed system
And that's going to create problems to the order of this many world
system. Which begs the question how many times has rick done this? if we look back at the end of Rick potion #9, Rick
seems oddly
Nonchalant about the whole burying his own dead body thing. While morty has a mind melting existential
crisis, Rick just grabs a beer and watches some TV. It's clear that this is not his first time at the rodeo.
He's done this before. As a matter of fact in the very first scene of the entire show, Rick destroys another world
Don't remember? Let's take a look. In the cold open to the pilot, Rick
drunkenly attempts to nuke the entire world in order to allow a fresh start. Even though Morty eventually talks him out of it, Rick
passes out before he can disarm the bomb. The countdown sequence gets closer and closer to launch, and we hear that the bomb is fully
armed right before the show takes us to the title sequence. But what happened that the show's creators aren't showing us
There's no way Morty,
who is characterized as naive and not brilliant, could figure
out how to stop the launch sequence himself. So boom, the show opens with Rick's favorite drunken pastime destroying an entire reality
I mean, if this is the kind of guy who had burned down his entire Brick-and-Mortar startup. Just because he got bored
There's little doubt he'll also destroy entire worlds when they start to tire on him
Maybe that's what the devil was referring to when he said this in the episode Something Ricked (This Way Comes). I mean seriously,
I may be the devil, but your grandpa is the devil. We really have no way of telling just what dimension
we're in or how many times Rick has hopped
realities. Heck, every time a new episode starts we could be in an entirely new dimension.
How about all the societal disillusionment brought up by the Cromulons and get Shwifty. Entire faiths are
dismantled due to the giant floating things in the sky that almost destroy the entire world. Yet
We see no remnants of the headist religion in any episodes that follow that's because that reality was left behind in between episodes
It's clear that Rick does a fair amount of interdimensional
Travel in between episodes as evidenced by the scan on his portal gun in close Rick counters of the Rick kind.
Who's to say that he comes back to the same reality every time? In all likelihood,
we're seeing a different reality
almost every time. But Matpat, (you're probably saying) he has to be in the same dimension throughout the show because he's referred to as
Earth Rick C-137. C-137
of course referring to the dimension he resides in. well the prevailing wisdom is that the episodes one through six of season one take
place in dimensions C-137. And after Rick and Morty cronenberg the world up in Rick potion #9, he travels to another unnamed
dimension but what makes us so sure that the initial dimension
We're watching is
C-137? If we think back to some of the details given to us throughout the series some things just don't add up. for one were
taught that Rick left Beth for 20 years before he moved into the garage and
Re-entered her life. Yet, in Close Rick-counters of the Rick kind,
We see some of Rick's memories projected onto the screen. One of them is holding baby morty
But that doesn't make sense. If rick has been gone for 20 years and Morty is still in high school,
then how could he be present for Morty's infancy? If Earth Rick
C-137's memories indicate a different history than the Beth of the initial dimension, there's no way that episode 1 through 6 took place in
C-137.
Truth is, Rick has hopped to and from so many dimensions, He doesn't even remember what dimension
He's in anymore. in the episode Morty Night Run, Rick and Morty drop Jerry off at a daycare
specially designed to keep Jerrys busy while their Rick's and Mortys are off on their irresponsible adventures now. What's telling here?
Is that when Rick is filling out the admissions paperwork he writes C-137 for his own dimension,
But N/A for Jerry's strange detail right no obviously this jerry doesn't exist in a paradoxical non dimension
He's from somewhere. So why does Rick write
Not applicable here? because Rick destroys and switches realities, so often that he isn't even sure which one
He's in at the moment, but the kicker for me is the show's intro in the final shot of the awesome opening sequence
We see a visual reference to HP lovecraft's cthulhu. A giant cosmic entity that's so widely known as the destroyer of worlds
So what's most interesting to me about this particular moment?
Is that most of the other clips in the series intro are later revealed in the context of a full episode.
This clip isn't anywhere to be found in any episode in either season one or season
two. So why include it especially?
Considering it takes up too much revered spot as the image that takes us to the title card well
It's not a mistake dear viewers,
It's a deliberate reference to Rick the world destroying terrorist who fancies himself a cosmic deity
He has the power to save or destroy entire worlds, and he is the reason I'm alive at all. But hey,
that's just a theory. A film theory! And,
cut.
If you want more Shwifty Rick and Morty action, Click here to check out my friends at Wisecrack and their video on the
Philosophy of Rick and Morty If you liked this video
You'll love that one covering everything from Cosmic body were to jerry being the everyman and finally before you go aim your portal gun
right here to subscribe to the film
Theorists why would you do that well duh for more cool videos like this you made it this deep into the video
So you must have really liked it. So why not keep the notifications coming?
I mean next episode is gonna be all about a marvel movie that I think everyone's really excited about so if you want to subscribe
To make sure that that one winds up in your feed it wouldn't be a bad idea just sayin. Make the smart call. subscribe. [Subtitles refined by SyncActual]